welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's always
merry and sorrow man for how bad the
puns are gonna be in this video the lord
of the rings the ring of power super
bowl trailer has just dropped and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down now super bowl
teasers are often short because they
cost more than mithril so to pad out the
video i'm also going to be talking about
the cast release date and everything we
know about the show you've got to hit
above that eight minute mark if you want
me roll ads and i've wasted enough of
your time so with that out of the way
let's get into the ring of power trailer
okay so as of now the ring of power is
the most expensive tv show of all time
back in 2017 the company purchased the
rights to the project for 250 million
dollars and since then they've been
working away to bring it to our screens
at the start of the year we got a title
sequence released on youtube that showed
it being formed from molten metal over
the top of it we heard galadriel
discussing the formation of the rings
which was taken word for word from the
fellowship prologue these rings as we
saw gave power to men the elves dwarves
and the dark lord sauron who you've
probably saw on tv look i didn't say the
puns were going to be good i didn't say
that now what we know about the series
is that it's going to be a loose prequel
to the movies and that it'll show the
creation of the rings rather than just
trying to redo what we had in the films
i think that this is a smart move as it
would be difficult to match the
spectacle of the movies and it would
also end up drawing direct comparison to
some of the best films ever made not you
now when discussing the series
showrunners jd payne and patrick mckay
said that the show will chronicle the
forging of the rings the rise of sauron
the fall of numenor and the alliance
between elves and men you might remember
in the movies that after defeating
sauron the parties involved in his
demise became fractured and the
fellowship was very much about bringing
these distant houses together the sharon
has said that we pretty much only know
the story of the one ring and that this
series will show us the others that
haven't really been touched upon outside
of the opening scenes of fellowship as
we know the men ended up becoming ring
rates and i think it's going to be
really interesting to see how they're
corrupted by the power that they bring
they all end up becoming twisted
creatures not really living but not dead
either i think that there's some really
fascinating things that they can do with
them sauron hasn't really taken that
much of a focus before either and though
he was obviously in the original trilogy
he was just basically an eye at the top
of a tower for the majority of the
movies we've never got to hear what he
thinks feels what his dreams are and the
fall of numenor could be something that
explores this numenor was an island that
men settled on and due to it being
surrounded by the ocean they became
great seamen
not like that don't don't ever think
like that now a map was released by
amazon that showed this area and it's
likely that we will see its downfall in
the main series now they were pretty
prosperous but like all men they faced
death sauron weaponized this fear and
their desire to become immortal like the
elves which may be a plot point that
pops up in the show he told them that he
could give them eternal life and that
all they had to do was join him in his
war against the gods they lost and the
gods angered by the island ended up
submerging it under the sea at the time
the earth was actually flat and the gods
reshaped it into a globe which caused
the oceans to change and massively kill
the majority of those on it those that
survived fled to middle earth and here
they form the kingdom of gondor in the
posters we can also see what might be
the scepter of anumanis
an anu anu
moving on now this belonged to a lindel
who managed to grab it whilst he fled
numenor he actually ended up forming
gondor so the series is sending out that
being a big plot point it's also
possible that a skill yet was also shown
in the first image released by amazon
this is a city that appeared in peter
jackson's movies and it's a place that
was almost reduced to rubble the image
also potentially showed the trees of
talpirion and lorien which were known to
light the world during the year of the
trees you can't see them with the
brightness turned up but if you darken
what appears to be the sun you can see
them there with a light emanating from
them sauron was connected to these two
and his lieutenant malcor started a war
that ended up with them being destroyed
this caused the guards to create the sun
and moon so that the world could have
light and whether this happens in the
series and art remains to be seen
galadriel is also of course going to be
playing a big part and in case you don't
know she's actually elrond's
mother-in-law so we might get some of
that relationship explored in the series
take my mother-in-law for example oh go
on take her
[Music]
now she of course possesses a ring of
power and i think that she's very much
gonna be a guide to the series that
fills us in on the big exposition dumps
and one of the promo shots we can catch
her meeting hal brand on a stormy sea
and there's also an image of her coming
up from the water this ties in heavily
with her origins and she will be played
by morphet clock according to the lore
at the time that the show takes place in
should just be hanging in the elf
capital of linden which we have had
glimpses at in the vanity fair article
now the trailer itself opens with the
kingdom of numenor in all its glory just
before its downfall this happened with
the drowning of the island kingdom by
the valor and it went down about as well
as this trailer did
[Music]
we will likely start here and then
culminate with the war of the last
alliance which was the really cool
prologue scene and fellowship of the
ring it's unclear which city and numenor
we see in the opening but the trailer
and voiceover make it clear that the
ring of power will be expansive and
adventurous with the trademark sweeping
vistas now just like the original
trilogy of books and movies it will
feature hobbits however the ones we're
dealing with are called harfords which
are one of three types of hobbits that
don't live in the shire we get a good
look at one as we see marcela cavanaugh
who will be playing a half foot and we
can see the smile which is a less
sophisticated hobbit hole than what we
saw in the shire something like boar out
there now we get a good look at
galadriel in action as she does her best
modern warfare 2 ice climbing activity
up the side of a mountain as mentioned
the show is set thousands of years
before we saw her in fellowship of the
ring and we know for better or worse
that this will be a prequel to the
movies she is said to be the commander
of the northern armies in the show
marking a major difference from the
source material galadriel will be
traveling across middle-earth and
considering that the second age featured
sauron's rise to power i think that she
will be investigating this which went
down worse worse than never mind i
really hope that amazon don't say this
as i do want to keep getting work from
them so stop watching the video if
you're jeff bezos anyway we see her
adventuring on horseback and also
fighting a monster in an ice cave and
she's definitely gonna prove that girls
get it done tying back to the shot from
before were also introduced to the new
character hal brand portrayed by charlie
vickers along with galadriel a pair
travelled together on a wrath in the
middle of the sundering sea we don't
know much about him but it has been said
that he has a dark past which he is
running from it is very bold of the
writers to go out and create original
characters but time will tell if it pays
off now we see another original
character named aaron diere who is a
sylvan elf you may remember them from
the hobbit movies which also featured a
original character for that trilogy
named tariel played by evangeline lilly
keep saying original characters and it's
doing my hitting now just like aragorn
and owen aaron dear is in a forbidden
relationship with a human woman called
bronin so it looks like they'll be
retreading the same ground in this
series next we catch enough that is none
other than gil galad the ruler of linden
we know from the law that he died whilst
fighting sauron in the war of the last
alliance but here he is at the height of
his power next we jump to prince jiren
whose father is the ruler of kazadoom
jiren would be the leader who took them
into battle at the last world alliance
and he was shown in flashbacks during
the fellowship prologue featured here is
also another original character named
princess dizer daisu will help rule over
kazadoom which is a location that
galadriel traveled through to get to
lothorian you can expect to see them
cross paths at some point whilst
galadriel goes to investigate sauron we
also get to see elrond who is played by
hugo weaving in the original movie
adaptations and he's someone that's
integral to the story of sauron's
downfall shown in the trailer is also a
bizarre shot of a man inside what looks
like a fiery explosion as per vanity
fair we know that the half foots will
find a lost man and that he's one of the
main mysteries in the show this is
evidently what we see here and please
can this actually lead somewhere unlike
the white walker mystery and origins and
game of thrones yes i'm still salty
lastly we cut to the battle between the
elves and the orcs this is a fight that
we've seen in the original trilogy which
is likely how the series will come to an
end the show is condensing canon so we
could actually be seeing the war of the
elves and sauron however it could be a
prologue to the series featuring the war
of the wraith which was an alliance of
dwarves early men and elves to defeat
the first star called melkor this closed
off the first stage and it would lead us
into the events of the second one maybe
in 20 years we will get a show called
before before before the rings of power
focusing on the first stage and then
let's just see how much amazon milks
this now as for my thoughts on the
trailer i am pretty mixed on it in all
honesty i know there's a lot of
discourse on the internet at the moment
with people slighting it and others
defending it to the death but personally
for me it just kind of sits in the
middle it doesn't look atrocious but i'm
also not seeing anything here that makes
me think it's going to live up to the
original trilogy the budget being a
billion is very expensive for something
that could end up tanking and i think
it's a big risk on amazon's part even
the like and dislike joke i keep doing
pretty much shows that everyone split
down the middle and yeah i feel that way
too i didn't hate it but i didn't like
it that much either so i really don't
know what to think bit of a bit of a
weird reaction to give but that's
honestly how i feel now i do have faith
that amazon can do it right and
obviously the boys and invincibles show
that they have the know-how to get
people involved that can knock stuff out
of the park i eagerly await a second
trailer but for now yeah not sure how i
feel which isn't really a good sign
doesn't really have many talking points
hey toilkin points are you having that
now the series drops in september and i
will of course be here with weekly
breakdowns on it so i hope to see you
there in the meantime i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of the june box set on the
28th of feb and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of the doctor strange trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we found loads of easter eggs in it
there's lots of plot points to talk
about too so definitely go head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for singing through the video
i've been paul i'll see you in the next
one take care peace